hey out there welcome in welcome welcome
welcome to another exciting ravishing
edition of Market takes listen I know
you could have been anywhere in the
world but you are right here with me on
Market takes I appreciate that I'm your
host Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal listen there is a lot
going on out there in the world we are
bringing you the three big things that
you need to be watching out for this
week we're going to tell you what those
are why they matter and why it why it's
meaningful to market the economy all
that good stuff so listen first we have
we are fully into earnings season at
this point but we have a big week this
week a lot of big Tech names are
reporting some banks uh we've got a big
mix we're going to tell you all about
what's happening and tell you what the
most important earnings reports are to
watch out for in terms of what that
could mean for the market to investors
and overall to the economy big picture
second we get the first look at U.S
first quarter GDP if you remember this
time last year here people weren't
really talking about the GDP report then
it came in negative was wildly
unexpected much lower and that led to a
lot of concerns the U.S was already in a
recession those fears have kind of
abated but this first quarter GDP report
comes with a lot of questions we are
going to get that and that's going to
answer a lot of questions about the
economy third we get two major reports
the two major reports on consumer
confidence and sentiment this week I'll
tell you what those are what to look out
for in each of those so without much
further Ado let's get into it earnings
listen we've already kicked things off
this week this morning we found out that
Credit Suisse lost more than 68 billion
dollars last week or last quarter excuse
me that was more than expected they also
borrowed more from Central Bank
liquidity backstop than had been
originally thought basically that just
means that Credit Suisse was in more
trouble than we expected than what we
thought uh writing down a lot of that
debt that highlights some of the
challenges ahead for UBS remember UBS
acquired Credit Suisse in that kind of
last minute last second deal where they
acquired it with help from the Swiss
government that was a big deal and this
now looks like man things could be even
worse for UBS maybe Credit Suisse and
those Bad Assets drag down UBS more than
more than worried about I want to read a
quick quote here from some analysts at
KBW
they said quote the revenue trajectory
is so damaged that the deal could well
remain a drag on UBS operating results
until a deeper restructuring plan is
announced all that means is there could
be more trouble maybe now at the bigger
Banks uh we heard from some of those big
Banks last week they look good JPMorgan
Chase if you remember 52 billion dollars
in profits big numbers big names so a
lot of those big Banks could be in solid
condition over here in the U.S but then
you look over there Europe will maybe
there are bigger problems keep that in
mind we are going to hear this week from
First Republic Bank now if you're
familiar with that name you're like why
do I why have I been hearing about First
Republic it's because that's really been
the subject of a lot of targeting uh the
stock has just been plummeting falling
off a cliff for a while and investors
it's been one of those banks that
investors have been worried about for
some time its stock price has tumbled
its market value has tumbled we're going
to hear from them what actually happened
at the bank how are they holding up and
that'll be a big piece of of this
overall Bank picture we're going to talk
about that in just a minute there have
been some big Winners and big losers
overall from these earnings reports
already last week we heard from Western
Alliance that said outflows they lost a
lot of money in deposits but that
stabilized and actually Rose two billion
dollars at the end or the first half of
April that stock up 24 last week
Metropolitan Bank deposits fell three
percent but they kind of chalk that up
to crypto losses less than expected
stock roads 15 for the week on the other
side of that some big losers truest Bank
another one of those kind of regional
behemoths that was created by the
combination of bb and t and SunTrust
deposits down at five percent from a
year earlier and down two percent from
the previous quarter that stock was down
five percent for the week Key Bank
another one of the bigger Regional Banks
deposits down three percent from a year
earlier and down one percent for the
previous quarter those shares were down
five percent last week so while you did
see some stocks do better than expected
or some banks uh really the overall mood
from investors was still negative on the
banking side sector and I want to put a
chart up here on your screen that really
kind of tells us what's so important
about this earnings week now the the the
line you see up there at the top that's
skying above all the rest that's the
NASDAQ 100. that's those big Tech names
you're talking meta you're talking
Amazon you're talking Microsoft all
those big big huge massive some of the
biggest countries come the biggest
companies excuse me in the U.S overall
that's what that is and we have seen
investors move into those big Tech names
and out of some of the others that's why
it's doing so much better than the S P
500 so far this year because investors
are really just seeking out the safety
or at least the supposed safety it seems
a bit like an oxymoron right because
Tech is generally thought of as risky as
a place where you might lose a lot of
your money but investors have been kind
of moving into the big Tech names as a
safe haven thinking that they're too big
to fail in a matter of spinking and
that's why the NASDAQ has done so well
this year the s p doing pretty well
about 15 year-to-date but not quite as
well and then you see on the lower half
that number that's down but 20
year-to-date that's those banking stocks
and even though you did see news that
wasn't as bad as expected that wasn't
worse than expected investors still
selling Banks not buying in yet you have
not seen Wall Street change its mind
about the big Banks and that's what's
there so that chart illustrating Just
the Way That Wall Street has been
thinking about the overall state of the
economy Banks Down and Out Tech doing
pretty well here's why this week could
be such a big piece of that or could
change that narrative
we've got a lot of money flowing into
big Tech a lot of the thinking is well
these companies are too big to fail but
they've also been announcing a lot of
layoffs doing a lot of things to kind of
patch up that bottom line right show
that they're making money doing what
Wall Street wants bringing in the
dollars we're going to find that if that
actually happened did those layoffs
actually create meaningful profits for
these big tech companies we are going to
hear from Microsoft alphabet Amazon and
meta all this week that's going to tell
us a lot about what the state of the
economy is now Wall Street Journal we
exclusively reported last week that meta
CEO Mark Zuckerberg had announced that
there weren't going to promise no more
layoffs they've already had huge layoffs
affecting about a quarter of the company
and Mark Zuckerberg said we we might
just have to do more layoffs so keep
your eye on those Tech earnings that
could if that bull falls out of tech you
could see the stock market overall move
meaningfully lower and that could be
some negative overall news for the US
economy especially as we have seen
layoffs start to pick up here as we've
seen jobless Flames pick up and all
those other things other companies to
watch this week you got Exxon and
Chevron the Big Oil Majors here in the
US Johnson Johnson Pfizer McDonald's
Verizon T-Mobile all this week as well
as visa and MasterCard so watch out for
those GDP coming in this week want to
put a chart up here on your screen it
just shows you what we've seen from GDP
overall you see over here to the right
of your screen you saw those two
negative quarters of GDP contraction
that we talked about the beginning of
2022 then GDP picked up getting back in
line with Trent expectations are for GDP
to come in under two percent for the
first quarter about 1.8 percent uh this
chart just illustrating the overall long
run theme when you take out those
pandemic swings 2021 was a big year but
now we're expecting lower growth and
less than two percent growth this uh
this first quarter
Ernst young or ey Chief Economist Greg
daco put it this way he said the economy
cap 2022 with pride but interest 2023
full of doubts I think that's a lot of
the worry here and if that number comes
in below expectations or even negative
again that's going to raise a lot of
fear about the US economy there are a
number of reasons to be worried that
that GDP figure could come in negative
even though Atlanta fed now Atlanta fed
GDP now is showing 2.5 percent way up
from point seven percent increase
expected so keep that in mind last chart
I want to put up here on your screen we
want to put that up right now to show
you consumer confidence this is the the
University of Michigan's consumer
sentiment index and as you can see it's
been moving higher that's good news it
means consumers are feeling good about
the economy it's part of why we've seen
spending continue but as we are seeing
Rising gas prices at the pump as we were
seeing higher oil prices as we are
seeing higher housing costs will that
continue and that's going to be a big
part of the overall theme that we will
see can those things continue that chart
just illustrating the overall change
that we have seen in consumer confidence
that it really plummeted and and
bottomed out and now we've seen a pickup
there conference board and the
University of Michigan both release
their consumer confidence and consumer
sentiment basically conference board has
a larger sample they survey more people
but the University of Michigan has more
detailed questions University of
Michigan consumer sentiment is really
how are you feeling what are you
thinking about the economy how do you
feel personally whereas the conference
board is what do you think about
business how are business conditions
doing they also look at the conference
board is better at picking up on
indicators related to the job market and
job security while the University of
Michigan survey much more a measure of
pocketbook issues how are you doing in
your life University of Michigan survey
is expected to ride to 63.5 up from last
month conference board expected to
decline you'll want to watch both of
those listen that's going to do it for
us here on Market takes for this week we
will be back with you again on Monday
looking ahead to what you need to be
looking out for that week but until then
thank you so much for being with us I am
Dion rabone reporter at the Wall Street
Journal and we will see you next time